et puis mon équipe elle est là pour
m'éviter aussi de déborder par exemple
si c'est golem de là je pense qu'elle
aurait coupé les caméras et les micros
depuis un certain temps en disant on va
arrêter parce que là ça va être ça sera
pas bon du tout pour l'image du ministre
mais on a bien fait de paniquer salut
vous l'avez compris en regardant le
titre aujourd'hui on va recevoir Olivier
Véran à la table alors quelle est
l'historique de cette vidéo tout d'abord
on avait fait la vidéo avec Bernard
Tellier le négociateur du GIGN qui
devait être une vidéo untshot et on a vu
vos retours on avait pris plaisir à
faire ça et on s'est dit on pourrait
continuer ses interviews en se
concentrant sur des hommes et des femmes
qui ont vécu quelque chose de
particulier et qui pourrait nous
raconter leur point de vue d'un point de
vue personnel et pas leur point de vue
de professionnel et là est né une idée
un petit peu folle je me suis dit est-ce
que ce serait pas fou de pouvoir poser
des questions à l'homme qui a confiné le
pays c'est c'était le nom de code du
projet l'homme qui a confiné le pays et
on s'est dit B6 serait dingue j'ai
essayé de contacter Olivier Véran j'ai
réussi à le contacter en disant
attention voici ce dont on va parler je
vais vous demander ça fait quoi de
machine un pays c'est quoi ce truc sur
les masques je vais aborder en fait tous
les sujets en lien avec ça pour avoir la
réponse de l'homme qui a derrière tout
ça et il m'a dit ok il est venu au
bureau petit disclaimer rapide je sais
que 50% des commentaires vont dire oh là
là il est trop verront pour Macron 50 %
des commentaires vont dire ah là là
c'est un antivirent et un anti Macron
c'est pas une vidéo de politique j'en ai
rien à faire que ce soit un homme
politique ce qui m'intéressait c'est
d'interviewer l'homme qui a signé en bas
je confine un pays et qui a traité cette
crise sanitaire là c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est toutes les émotions
tout ce qu'il a pensé tout ce qu'il a
ressenti ce n'est pas une vidéo
politique ça ne m'intéresse pas et voici
cette vidéo j'aime beaucoup les petites
cartes c'est vrai que ça te va si on se
tutoie sur l'interview Fabien tu peux me
tutoyer si tu es d'accord je te tutorais
aussi alors tutoyer en nous ça me va
très bien toute cette petite situation
en tant que ministre de la Guerre de la
santé et de la santé comment on le vit
en vrai est-ce qu'on est préparé pour ça
dans sa vie et c'est plein de questions
sur ce sujet-là que je vais te poser
aujourd'hui ok ça te va c'est ton bien
parce que je peux pas écrire les
questions les et en fait c'était le soir
du premier confinement on avait passé
une journée Dingo ça commence par un
message du président de la République
qui me dit on va y aller pour le
confinement point d'interrogation la
journée je sors de mon lit j'appelle les
équipes branle-bas de combat c'est bon
on y va on prépare tout donc c'était une
journée absolument dingue il a fallu
gérer ça d'un point de vue technique et
en même temps il y avait une partie de
ma tête qui ne pouvait pas ne pas se
projeter dans ce que ça allait impliquer
dans le quotidien des gens confinement
restez chez soi ne plus pouvoir sortir
sauf exception arrêter ses activités les
gamins qui vont plus à l'école les
magasins qui sont fermés et en fait la
journée se prépare tout est tout est en
place le président va faire son
intervention le soir pour annoncer le
confinement d'ailleurs il prononcera pas
le mot de confinement à la télé et c'est
moi qui dans l'émission que je fais pour
TF1 juste après j'y confirme que c'est
bien un confinement et en fait j'appelle
la mère de mes enfants pour la prévenir
en fait que je vais pas revenir avoir un
moment et que ça va être dur et qu'il
faut qu'on soit contiennent tous quoi
dans la tête c'est allé très vite je me
suis projeté à la place de quelqu'un qui
vit dans un deux pièces avec quatre
enfants dans la place de quelqu'un qui
me personne âgée une seule qui recevra
plus les visites habituelles dans la
place de quelqu'un qui pourra plus aller
bosser normalement dans la place comme
si je j'avais l'impression de me
projeter dans plein de vie à la fois
donc vraiment une prise de conscience de
ce que ça allait impliqué dans la vie
des gens espèce de bouffer émotionnel
assez forte et quand la journée se
termine quand les caméras de TF1 qui te
met au bureau après l'interview je
m'assois à ma table je prends deux
feuilles blanches et je commence à
écrire OK et j'ai écrit le contenu de la
journée et guider un peu par l'émotions
après c'est plus rien écrit pendant des
mois même pendant longtemps en fait et
puis j'ai rééprouvé le besoin d'écrire
après un raid un peu bizarre j'ai appelé
la conférence de presque où j'étais avec
Jean Castex et on annonçait absolument
n'importe quoi c'est un rêve un peu
bizarre de genre de micro sieste qu'on
fait au milieu de la journée qui fait
qu'on s'épuise si on vit ou si on rêve
et en prévient j'ai décidé d'écrire donc
j'ai tout écrit sous le coup de en fait
c'est pas exhaustif c'est pas récit
exhaustif c'est pas daté enfin c'est
daté mais il y a pas il y a pas tous les
événements par contre c'est que des
trucs qui ont qui évoquent encore chez
moi à posteriori un souvenir
suffisamment fort pour que j'ai tous les
détails qui reviennent ah c'est
intéressant c'est à dire que la
mécanique de départ c'est c'est le
fameux truc on met sur le papier pour
savoir mieux un peu ce qu'on pense et ce
qu'on ressent on sait vraiment ce qu'on
pense une fois qu'on a mis de l'énergie
soit en verbalisant si on l'écrivant
donc il y avait peut-être aussi un
besoin un peu d'expulser ça l'exus
l'exutoire et puis aussi le besoin de
témoigner médecin hospitalier Grenoble
Loire paire de famille et tout d'un coup
bam ministre de la guerre à te voir des
prendre des décisions et tout ça en
quelques jours et donc parfois les
Français nous voient parce qu'on a un
mandat parce qu'on a des fonctions comme
des incarnés comme si on était différent
de même en fait on a une vie qui est
différente de la lame on est exactement
pareil et quand je rentre le week-end
chez moi à Grenoble je vais voir les
copains que j'ai gardé depuis le lycée
il me traite comme n'importe qui et
c'est très bien et heureusement en fait
et moi je voudrais pouvoir aller dans
une grande surface faire mes courses en
short quand il fait chaud sans avoir des
gens qui regardent ce que je vais
acheter derrière etc moi j'aspire avant
la ville la plus normale possible par
contre les fonctions que j'ai occupées à
ce moment-là faut que j'étais amené à
prendre des décisions à expliquer à
parler à 60 millions de Français et donc
j'ai trouvé que c'était plutôt plutôt
légitime en tout cas que c'était vous
pouvez être intéressant pour les gens de
se mettre peut-être à la place qui a pu
être la mienne et de regarder en fait le
déroulé des événements pour dynamiser la
vidéo on va aussi illustrer la vidéo
avec tes propos donc je voudrais Olivier
vérans en short qui fait ses courses
tu fais tes études de médecine à quel
moment tu comprends tu vas faire de la
politique est-ce que tu as pour projet
de d'avoir un vrai parcours politique
qui termine par un ministère par exemple
comment ça se passe alors j'ai pas
projeté de faire de la politique par
contre j'ai toujours été passionné par
ces trucs là c'est en moi depuis que je
suis tout petit j'ai le souvenir de moi
à 10 ans dans ma ville ou mes parents
habitaient en train de dessiner un
portrait de Lucky Luke pour faire une
affiche électorale pour être élu au
conseil municipal enfants genre
démissionne au bout de quatre mois en
déchirant ma carte parce que le conseil
municipal enfants avait voté pour un
projet et le projet était pas tout à
fait le même quand on a vu la
réalisation
d'un panneau de sécurité routière qui
est toujours là d'ailleurs on avait
choisi le dessin c'était pas le dessin
qu'on avait choisi c'était sur le
panneau donc le colère après non j'étais
délégué de classe j'ai jamais cherché à
être numéro 1 j'aimais bien d'ailleurs
être plutôt conseil dans l'ordre de gens
que j'aimais bien et les accompagner et
puis par accident quasiment je me suis
retrouvé député en fait c'est la députée
de ma mon territoire qui est venu me
chercher je faisais pas de politique
j'étais en quartier nulle part et par
contre comme elle voyait bah j'étais
médecin j'avais mené un peu des
mouvements étudiants et m'a proposé de
l'accompagner puis je me suis retrouvé
député en trois semaines et j'ai
rencontré le président de la République
et qui était ministre est-ce que tu
commences à un député suppléance et d'un
coup ben en fait le suppléant devient le
député parce que pas le choix et j'étais
je découvre que je vais être député
devant la télé avec mon fils à l'époque
des tout petit dans les bras je regarde
la domination du gouvernement puis
j'entends la députée que je supplie qui
est ministre et donc je comprends que je
vais être député de ta sortie je
comprenais pas mon téléphone
en disant mais tu ne l'as pas dit ben je
savais pas en fait et donc du coup
député comme ça ma doctrine c'est le
hasard favorise les esprits préparés
c'est pasteur j'aime beaucoup ça ça veut
dire qu'il y a des choses qu'on ne
détermine pas soi-même ou qu'on fait
peut-être inconsciemment mais qui vont
nous arriver parce qu'on s'y prépare
dans ton livre à un moment donné tu
détailles le logement de fonction les
obligations ménagères financières qui
incombe le ménage la taxe d'habitation
ce genre de choses c'est pas du tout ce
qu'on imagine c'était important de
rendre ça transparent aussi de se dire
vous voulez la vision de l'homme bah
voilà la vision de l'homme c'est j'ai
des obligations de ménage de finances la
taxe d'habitation c'est moi qui la paix
c'est la première question qu'on compose
en fait quand je vais voir les champions
de savoir combien vous gagnez bon ben
voilà 6005 après la peau et donc une
fois qu'on a dit ça avant d’accord c'est
beaucoup d'autres est-ce que pour bien
comprendre ton logement il est dans le
ministère de la Santé à ce moment-là
ouais en fait heureusement parce qu'en
fait le rythme de vie pendant la crise
fait que j'aurais dormi dans mon bureau
en fait sinon ce qui en fait ça s'arrête
jamais
et les mauvaises nouvelles tombées
volontiers très tard le soir ou très tôt
le matin et donc en fait j'ai j'avais
mon bureau très beau bureau puis un
couloir puis on tourne et là il y a mon
logement de fonction il y a 50 mètres à
faire donc je faisais pendant le
confinement peut-être 300 pas par jour
j'ai pas trop grossi parce que j'avais
pas beaucoup le temps de manger 9 jours
[Musique]
d'israalement le ministre suites le
ministre autrichien il reçoit des SMS
pour leur dire qu'il y a des premiers
cas chez eux donc moi je rentre de Rome
et j'appelle le président
des menaces d'épidémie à tous les 5 à 10
ans de menace de pandémie avec des virus
très sévères mais sans qu'on sache
pourquoi il y en a certains qui ont pas
passé la frontière de l'Asie qui sont
restés des épidémies localisées et
d'autres qui sont arrivés en France mais
qu'on fait quelques centaines de malades
et là c'est la déférence sur l'Italie
donc on se dit en fait pour l'instant
c'est sous contrôle en France
paradoxalement on a je crois même plus
de cas
identifiés en France à ce moment-là mais
aussi en fait il suffit d'un truc pour
que ça puisse péter et le truc ça a été
Mulhouse et toi quand tu rentres de
l'Italie tu te tu te dis quoi sur ce
confinement tu dis on s'en fout ou on va
pas tarder à le faire on risque de le
faire ou tu vois comment tu jauges c'est
le fait de confiner le pays tu vois tu
dis c'est ce que j'appelle la bascule
ça bascule c'est le moment où chacun
d'entre nous a percuté que c'était grave
et que ça allait être une période qui
avait rien d'ordinaire quand j'arrive en
Italie je me dis les mecs ont fermé les
écoles sur quels critères et surtout
quand est-ce qu'ils vont les rouvrir en
fait donc j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
d'interrogations et mes collègues des
autres pays européens comme moi et
d'être confronté la situation italienne
de voir ce qui est en train de se passer
quand je rentre d'Italie je me dis
c'est pas impossible qu'on soit obligé
de le faire pas forcément mais c'est pas
impossible qu'on soit obligé de le faire
et en fait ça va très très vite et ça
veut dire que quand toi tu rentres ce
constat là c'est toi qu'on est porteur
après qui va aussi de voir sûrement en
parler à tes équipes à tes collègues à
ton président etc de dire bah voilà moi
quand j'y suis allé je me suis un peu
tout match et en fait en rentrant tu dis
c'est pas impossible quoi c'est pas
possible mentalement il a fallu ensuite
en fait j'ai vu les gens autour de moi
basculer aussi jour après jour et même
le soir on est tous au ministère de la
Santé tout un chapitre on est autour
d'une grande table et on décide de
fermer toutes les activités dites non
essentielles et en fait autour de la
table il y a des gens qui comprennent
pas en fait et il y en a un qui vient me
voir quelqu'un très bien mais qui vient
voir et qui me dit mais vous êtes des
malades mais qu'est-ce que vous êtes en
train de faire et moi j'ai mis en fait
on n'a pas le choix on va pas avoir le
choix il faut qu'on fasse parce que
sinon plus on attend plus ce sera tard
et puis il y aura des dégâts qu'on
pourra pas rattraper donc il faut disons
qu'on a finalement pris des décisions
assez tôt parce que factuellement quand
on prend la décision de fermer le pays
les RE sont pas saturé mais on sait que
vu le nombre de réa qu'on a déjà
enregistré ça va ça va faire que monter
dans les jours et les semaines qui vont
suivre donc il faut immédiatement
arrêter la circulation du virus il faut
la couper et en fait il y a pas de
manuel de gestion d'une pandémie on fait
rien de différent finalement de ce qu'on
faisait il y a un siècle pendant la
grippe espagnole la seule truc qu'on
peut contrôler c'est les interactions
sociales c'est à dire aux gens en fait
vous approchez plus les uns des autres
et donc le seul moyen c'est d'arrêter
c'est la distanciation donc c'est éviter
de regrouper les gens dans le même
endroit et ensuite dire aux gens le jour
où je dis aux gens de plus serrer la
main et on a pris pour un pour un bain
Go certain mon ruban adago c'était assez
tôt d'ailleurs et je prends la décision
tout seul dans la voiture qui m'emmène
dans l'Oise c'est un Crépy-en-Valois
parce qu'il y avait un instituteur un
prof de collège qui venait de décéder du
covid qui était en bonne santé jusqu'ici
et aujourd'hui en fait on circule la
main on s'embrasse plus et on est à
France en fait et très vite en fait les
gens ont pris le réflexe depuis serrer
la main et de faire la distanciation et
en fait on efface quand je dis qu'il y a
pas de manuel c'est qu'il y a pas un
guide de bonne pratique de qu'est-ce
qu'on fait en situation de pandémie
maintenant on a beaucoup appris on a des
retours d'expérience on ferait pas la
même chose dans les mêmes conditions si
à nouveau virus revenait donc cette
connaissance qu'on a acquise en France à
l'étranger de comment on fait face à ce
type de virus il faut surtout qu'on la
garde et qu'on l'entretienne est-ce que
c'est pas ça le plus difficile pourtant
quand tombe à ce moment-là d'essayer de
faire comprendre ce que c'est la
contagion et que vraiment chaque coup
compte ça peut être n'importe où
n'importe quand quoi ouais et puis au
début on sait pas
au début on sait pas comment ils se
transmet les premières semaines on le
dit que c'est une transmission Manu
portée c'est-à-dire au passage de la
main à l'autre et ensuite on se gratte
le visage en dessous du virus partout
imagine imagine que je te serre la main
que toi tu es porteur du virus donc ma
main elle se colore en bleu et puis je
me touchais le visage et en fait après
on nous dit qu'en fait le coronavirus là
contrairement à d'autres il se transmet
aussi par gouttelette c'est-à-dire au
moment où je te parle là tu vois pas je
suis désolé c'est pas hyper agoutant
mais c'est une petite gouttelettes qui
vont de toi à moi était moi à toi quand
on se parle et c'est gouttelettes elles
sont chargées de virus et qu'en fait
elles vont s'étaler un peu de partout et
on va se contaminer c'est une menace ah
non pas du tout c'est impossible c'est
un conseil maintenant
on y reviendra l'état de la connaissance
qui augmente tous les jours et donc qui
parfois affirme corrige confirme des
choses de la veille qui a été qui a été
aussi dur je pense à prendre en compte
pour tout à chacun surtout ceux qui et
j'en fais partie sur moi suivez moins
assidûment que le ministère de la Santé
ce qui se passait et donc des fois il y
avait des trucs attends sert pas la main
mais alors maintenant on ne dit que ça
aéroporté mais alors c'est quoi le truc
et tous les masques
mais dès lors que ça se transmet par
gouttelettes mais ça veut dire qu'il
faut me mettre un masque parce que ça
évite que mes projections sur toi que
tes projections étaient sur moi au
moment où vous dites faut pas de masque
c'est quoi votre motivation et du coup
c'est celle-ci alors c'est qu'en fait tu
as tout un tas de publications qui
montrent c'est le cas dans la grippe par
exemple que ça n'a pas de d'apport
collectif de porter un masque en période
d'épidémie grippal sur d'autres
coronavirus qui n'avaient pas le même
mode de transmission une coronale le
covid 19 il est issu d'une longue lignée
de coronavirus et d'autres coronavirus
on n'avait pas déterminé qui se
transmettait comme ça par gouttelettes
et donc si tu veux c'était pas d'utilité
particulière on pensait que c'était
uniquement en cas de de fortes charges
virales de quelqu'un très contaminé avec
ce qu'on appelait des des sécrétions
profondes donc on en mettait au médecin
au dentiste parce que eux ils peuvent
être confrontés à des tous c'est
quelqu'un de tous dans la figure c'est
pas pareil mais en fait que il y a
certains virus si je suis au bout de la
pièce
[Musique]
de quitter de dire on n'avait pas de
raison de penser qu'il fallait porter un
masque mais on s'est planté c'est dur de
dire que on s'est planté en politique la
science parfois elle se plante et la
médecine parfois te donne plein de
conseils et elle se plante dans les
années 80 les bouquins les livres de
gynécologie obstétrique recommandées aux
femmes enceintes de boire entre 1 et 3
verres de d'alcool par jour donc parfois
la science elle carotte parfois elle se
plante et surtout avant d'affirmer
quelque chose il faut il faut être sûr
que ce soit démontré par les faits on en
parlera après j'imagine avec le
chloroquine qui était à l'opposé de la
démarche scientifique et donc la
démarche antique c'est ça et là en
l'occurrence les seuls fait
scientifiques sur lesquels on pouvait se
fonder ils étaient plutôt de nature à
nous dire de pas porter de masse et en
fait en France on bouge je sais plus en
avril ou au début mai en disant en fait
il faut emporter et l'OMS l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé elle va mettre deux
mois de plus avant de dire en fait il
faut emporter donc en fait c'était
c'était mondial comme si j'avais par
contre en France ça a pris une une
ampleur
inégalée à l'étranger c'est-à-dire qu'à
l'étranger ça a été moins un problème
ils
pas davantage au début ils emportaient
autant que nous après donc c'est un
mélange de tout ça mais de fait on s'est
planté et donc il faut savoir le
reconnaître donc on m'a dit mais vous
vous êtes vous êtes vous excusez pour
une erreur bah ouais en fait oui on fait
bien mais je différencie moi je me suis
soigné en faisant des saigner c'est très
efficace je rigole ça a été une blague
je reviens sur le confinement juste sur
le petit point commun réagissent tes
collaborateurs c'est-à-dire que je sais
que c'est une fourmilier un ministère ça
se passe comment en interne qu'est-ce
que toi tu vis quand tu marches dans les
couloirs est-ce que tu dis bon là ils
vont tous me sauter dessus et m'attaquer
ou ça va globalement tout le monde on
avait le même niveau de connaissance et
on partageait tout d'ailleurs mais mes
conseillers ont été héroïques ils
dormaient dans le bureau sur des lits de
camps on était confinés entre nous
espèce de bulle on partageait tout moi
je partage beaucoup avec mes conseillers
je vais dans leur bureau plutôt que les
convoquer on se tutoie le contact c'est
le côté médical un peu genre dans la
salle de garde salut les gars comment ça
va donc on est très comme ça on fait une
équipe je dis pas qu'il travaille pour
moi mais avec moi et c'est pas démago
c'est qu'en fait j'ai besoin de ça tout
simplement c'est même égoïste j'ai
besoin de sentir proche les gens avec
qui je travaille et le si j'ai une
conseillère il m'a engueulé pendant des
semaines pour les musées des bâtiments
patrimoniaux et ensuite pour tout
miloculturel dont tu te rends pas compte
il faut arrêter donc il y avait des
désaccords on est on les mettait sur la
table après c'est pas toutes les
décisions qu'on a prises c'était
collégiales c'est pas moi dans mon
bureau qui a dit alors on va faire du
tout comme ça que ça marche il y a les
scientifiques d'un côté les politiques
des réunions interministérielles on
présente ça au Premier ministre au
président de la République on discute on
échange et à la fin on acte une décision
qui va bien à tout le monde et en se
disant bon ben on a ce qu'on a d'autres
options est-ce qu'il y a des
alternatives et quand on a affiné le
sujet et qu'on voit qu'en fait la
trajectoire la plus sûre c'est celle-ci
on s'y tient mais oui il peut y avoir
des divergences de d'opinion des uns des
autres d'ailleurs c'est très simple
parce que nous on a tous tendance quand
je dis nous c'est les personnes qui sont
non liées à la politique on a tous
tendance à rapporter après la décision
au Messager donc en fait au ministre de
la Santé publique
bah oui on termine avec le moment où
vraiment tu signes le confinement alors
je dis tu signes de confinement j'en
sais fiche trop ment rien qu'est-ce qui
se passe est-ce que le il y a un point
clé où tu as un stylo dans la main ou tu
signes un papier et c'est ça qui
enclenche tout ce qui a un moment donné
où tu es tout seul et que tu vas appuyer
sur un bouton c'est quoi qui se passe et
qu'est-ce que toi tu ressens en tant que
comme à ce moment-là what ça se passe un
peu comme ça tout est collégial tout est
collectif mais une fois qu'on a décidé
alors c'est pas sur le confinement
c'était sur juste avant le 14 mars ok on
commence à 21h30 22h on se réunit et on
se dit bon le Premier ministre vient
d'annoncer qu'on allait arrêter toutes
les activités non essentielles dans le
pays non mais du coup c'est alors
qu'est-ce qui est essentiel et qu'est-ce
qui n'est pas et en fait la Constitution
elle dit que prier manifester c'est
essentiel pour le reste c'est d'avoir
donc on discute et on dit bon ben
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des des magasins
l'alimentation c'est essentiel donc on
doit ok mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
autres magasins tout ce qui est pas
essentiel on ferme ok mais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des magasins qui vendent à la
fois de la nourriture et des trucs par
exemple
[Musique]
hyper important de ressentir les choses
hyper important de douter hyper
important de recevoir les claques qu'on
prend parfois dans la gueule de se
remettre en question par contre ne pas
se laisser couler c'est-à-dire savoir
pourquoi est-ce qu'on décide ça assumer
la décision quand on l'a prise y compris
publiquement et l'apporter l'expliquer
c'est un peu comme un médecin en fait
j'allais venir là-dessus un peu
mentaliste parce que tu as ma prochaine
fille tu écris un moment donné les
Français ne sont pas mes patients je
suis pas leur médecin pour moi au fond
de toi ton passif de médecin va t'amener
aussi peut-être à une communication
différente à des des zooms différents à
apprendre aussi de la distance avec
certaines décisions aussi peut-être etc
tu as été un peu quand même notre
médecin ou en tout cas notre médecin
référent qui nous disait un peu l'état
de santé d'un pays et d'une population
disons en médecine tu décides et tu
t'assumes moi j'étais neurologue
vasculaire donc tu as un patient qui
arrive avec un artère bouchée dans le
cerveau il faut décider si on va la
déboucher ou pas et comment la débouche
et on n'a pas le temps de se poser
pendant une semaine pour concerter les
gens pour savoir ce qu'ils en pensent en
fait il faut décider pour les gens donc
on débouche on ne bouge pas en fonction
de la situation derrière on explique on
assume comment on explique on fait on
livre une information claire loyale
appropriée c'est le terme qu'on a du
qu'on utilise en médecine on se met à
hauteur de personnes on s'assure que les
gens y compris et ils sont que moi je
suis neurologue tu connais bien la
neurologie on a des maladies hyper
compliquées c'est pour ça que j'ai
choisi la neuro d'ailleurs parce qu'il y
a plein de trucs qu'on comprend pas les
troupes cognitifs on comprend pas les
maladies etc et donc moi je fais souvent
des schémas en fait à mes malades
quelqu'un qui a 18 ans qui a une
sclérose en plaques donc c'est une
maladie qui dégrade le cerveau
progressivement et la moelle épinière
mais qui va très bien mais on a fait le
diagnostic il faut lui donner un
traitement qui peut être parfois très
lourd avec des effets indésirables et
bien pour que la personne qui va très
bien accepte de prendre ce traitement
qui va éviter que son cerveau se dégrade
il faut s'assurer qu'il a compris si on
explique si on s'assure que les gens ont
compris si on leur donne une information
claire loyale appropriée en général les
gens ils acceptent parce qu'ils savent
pourquoi ils ont ils prennent une
décision plutôt qu'une autre donc ça
c'est le côté rapport un peu médical et
ensuite avoir été toubib être toubib ça
m'a permis de comprendre comment
fonctionner l'épidémie comment le virus
se transmettait ce que c'est qu'un
syndrome de détresse respiratoire aigu
quels sont les traitements potentiels de
connaître le fonctionnement de l'hôpital
et donc ça a été hyper précieux je dis
pas qu'il faut forcément être médecin
pour être mis à la santé
vaut mieux enfin c'est un gain de temps
considérable donc le moment où tu signes
ton arrêté c'est
quand même le le la séparation et un peu
compliqué à ce moment-là quand même bah
ouais non c'est des moments qui sont
compliqués des moments compliqués qu'on
vit vraiment qu'en tout cas que j'ai
vécu dans ma chair quand on était à
l'air de la visioconférence
une fois il y a quelqu'un qui ne branche
pas sa caméra et je suis en train de
discuter avec lui tu voulais pas
brancher votre caméra ce sera plus
simple et il me dit mais j'ai pas envie
que vous voyez là où je vis parce que
j'en ai honte en fait c'est c'est pas
une anecdote qu'on entend comme ça c'est
un truc à chaque fois moi je percute en
disant c'est vrai que c'est ça que les
gens vivent en fait et nous on est au
ministère on a nos caméras dans ma
chambre en fait tout est percuté dans le
quotidien des Français parlons du
docteur Raoult et surtout de l'hydroxyde
ainsi il faut en parler non mais
j'aimerais question quand il annonce
l'hydroxy chloroquine alors je vais
mettre d'ailleurs moi je vois les vidéos
de Dhu déjà quand il dit qui se conclut
par et donc c'est la grippe la plus
facile à soigner qu'on a eu nanana
hahaha on a gagné quoi billet de
d'autorité par rapport à ce que je sais
lui je me dis bon bah c'est quand même
une bonne nouvelle ça sonne un peu comme
un miracle mais ça déclaration elle
fonctionne sur moi à ce moment-là et je
me suis posé la question du coup est-ce
que toi il y a un moment donné où tu as
cru à ses effets d'annonce avant d'aller
creuser ce que tu dis super apparemment
on a trouvé un super truc ou assez tôt
toi tu as tu avais toutes les cartes en
main pour te dire bah non dangereux ou
est-ce que tu as juste douté tu vois moi
je suis comme tout le monde j'ai la
trouille les virus la trouille des
conséquences du virus je cherche une
réponse j'ai besoin de conjurer la peur
et de me raconter à quelque chose donc
moi quand il y a un grand scientifique
qui dit j'ai trouvé un traitement le
premier réflexe c'est de me dire
peut-être que ça marche mais j'ai le
côté néocortex scientifique qui reprend
tout de suite le dessus en disant mais
comment il peut savoir que ça marche et
la médecine en fait ça marche sur
l'épreuve sur l'expérience sur les
études il faut des publications on peut
pas décréter qu'on a trouvé quelque
chose en fait il faut la tester je cite
entre les deux c'est à dire je me dis
quoi qu'il arrive je bougerai pas une
oreille sur la chloroquine enfin je ne
libérerai pas la prescription de
chloroquine tant que j'aurais pas la
preuve le ça marche et que ça ne nuit
pas aux gens premier point deuxième
point la partie qui a envie d'y croire
parce qu'on sait jamais fait que je
m'assure parce que c'est un labo
français qui produit qu'on en a des
stocks qu'on est en capacité d'en
produire et surtout je j'active tout ce
que je peux pour développer des études
cliniques c'est à dire pour démontrer
c'est le traitement est efficace ou non
oui non mais c'est intéressant tu le
rejette pas je ne rejette pas par
principe
non c'est c'est une hérésie scientifique
que auréolée d'une autorité allait
décréter qu'on a fait de la science sans
faire de la science ça n'existe pas ça
existe dans l'histoire plein de choses
comme ça dans l'histoire avec des gens
qu'on va affirmer des contre-vérités
avec suffisamment de confiance et
suffisance pour que les gens ils croient
il y en a plein et c'est les allumettes
les amulettes établissements d'une
petite pierre à Loïc mon cadreur qui
éloigne les crocodiles Loïc t'as jamais
eu de crocodile chez toi voilà ça marche
très très bien écoute combien cette
bière on en parle après
le premier principe de la médecine c'est
primum de nos séries premièrement ne pas
nuire et et elle est déterminer comme ça
que moi j'ai trouvé ce qui va vous
guérir alors que c'est quand même un
médicament qui peut avoir des impacts
sur la santé des gens c'est pas bon
ça n'existe pas ça ne doit pas hésiter
pas dans une société moderne et mature
et puis ils se sont engouffrés là-dedans
plein de gens qui ont témoigné en fait
ben moi j'ai une covid et grâce à la
chloroquine du docteur raout deux jours
de fièvre j'ai guéri mais c'est
formidable c'est le cas de 90% des gens
qui prennent du paracétamol et en fait
on est plus dans un discours rationnel
et donc tout un tas de contre vérité
parce que après il a commencé à dire
dans dans mon hôpital j'ai pas un seul
malade en réanimation oui parce que tu
n'as pas un seul lit de réanimation donc
factuellement il dit la vérité peut pas
lui dire qu'il a menti mais il oublie de
dire qu'il a pas de livret A et que tous
ces malades qui s'aggravent ils partent
dans les octonauts de Marseille qui eux
reçoivent les malades du docteur Raoul
qui n'ont pas répondu la chloroquine et
qui se sont regardées donc c'est c'est
hyper compliqué à gérer honnêtement
c'est une période qui est compliqué
parce que il faut tenir donc ne pas
céder face aux demandes aux pression
avec des collectifs de gens qui
commencent à signer des trucs en disant
on est la seule des labos enfin le truc
habituel quoi quand les gens ont peur ça
peut déclencher des réactions
paradoxales un peu pénible et en même
temps faire progresser la recherche et
la science et donc maintenant avec le
recul plus personne honnêtement à part
quelques affichésiens de Raoul de
considère que la chloroquine est la
moins utilité il y a des présidents qui
ont de certains pays qui ont disparu de
la chloroquine qui ont eu s’excuser
publiquement je pense au Brésil par
exemple moi j'attends de voir à quel
moment le docteur out considéra qui
s'est planté en fait ah c'est pas c'est
pas dit moi je me souviens de ses
annonces où je fais pour moi-même en
permanence ce petit décryptage non
verbal pour voir et une chose est sûre
pour moi dans mon opinion c'est qu'il
était vraiment convaincu de ce qu'il
amenait et après dans le temps j'ai vu
que cette force de conviction a commencé
à disparaître mais qu'il était rentré
dans un truc de cohérence qui évitait la
dissonance cognitive de je vais jusqu'au
bout et si c'est vraiment jusqu'au
boutiste il y aura pas de marche arrière
je le vois pas après je me disais du
coup que toi en tant que ministre de la
Santé ce moment où tu prends la double
précaution il y a aussi du coup cette
gestion dans ta vie privée et dans la
vie publique de ministre de tous ceux
qui croient ou tous ceux qui ont envie
d'y croire qui comme moi ont vu deux
trois trucs et se disent bah alors ils
font quoi on a trouvé quelque chose
et surtout que vous n'avez rien à
annoncer d'autres c'est pas ne prenez
pas de la chloroquine prenez le
médicament machin qui va vous guérir on
n'a pas encore de vaccins on n'a pas de
traitement efficace donc en fait
la magie de la science c'est qu'elle
prend du temps mais que quand elle
trouve elle trouve la science de la
magie je la connais pas puisqu'elle
affirme par définition et elle a pas
besoin de démontrer puisque elle affirme
et qui parle moi je l'appelle une espèce
de chaman MacGyver tout un peu tout
Chatou qui a la tête plus grande
institut hospitalier universitaire de
leur maladie infectieuses qui a des
moyens considérables qui a fait des
trucs pas mal à côté de ça sur les tests
sur les et qui a cette gouaille mais en
fait il s'en sert me semble-t-il pas
dans le sens de l'intérêt général dans
la mesure où parce que c'est un
scientifique parce qu'il est entouré de
blouse blanche il connaît le principe
premier de la médecine d'abord de bannir
toi en tant qu'homme et en tant que
médecin tu lui en veux dans le fond un
espèce de truc de tu nous as mis les
bâtons dans les roues frérot tu on fait
le même métier à la base mince ou non
moi j'ai une relation particulière avec
lui il m'envoie des textos très vite
se raconte dans le bouquin les échanges
de texto qu'on a oui des fois il pique
le démon je n'ai plus de chloroquine
j'en veux pour mes malades si tu m'en
donnes pas je vais faire une conférence
de prêt je vais vous allumer puis après
il commence à partir sur d'autres
terrains
vas-y vas-y comment ça va m'appeler tu
sais beaucoup de gens disent que j'aurai
faire de la politique que j'aimerais me
présenter mais moi je fais pas de
politique
présente-toi enfin c'est pas le sud
c'est pas le sujet en fait le sujet
c'est juste que non je ne te laisserai
pas
faire n'importe quoi et donc je veux
bien continuer d'accueillir la science
de faire des recherches d'aider
d'appuyer pour qu'on puisse démontrer ce
truc est efficace ou non manifestement
ne l'est pas si il est non seulement il
ne l'est pas si non si voilà ça continue
comme ça mais je reste ferme sur les
bases et donc ça on chemine comme ça
jusqu'au jour où c'est honnêtement il
est tombé un peu en plus personne n'est
pas une chloroquines et puis moi j'ai
arrêté de lui répondre parce que c'est
les autres choses à faire du coup j'ai
fait même les une analyse sur toi sur
les discours etc et ça va tu es venu
donc tu m'en veux de rien
[Rires]
est-ce que en vrai il y a encore de la
place pour la spontanéité quand tu
faisais tes prises de parole ou est-ce
que tout doit passer sous le CRIP de la
conseillère en communication le dos ça
dépend du moment parce que pour moi j'ai
vu beaucoup d'endroits où tu étais
freestyle dans le bon sens du terme je
me suis même demandé si c'était un
calcul de ta part de se dire je vais
moins préparer comme ça on verra aussi
le naturel qui a derrière et que je
trouvais intéressant non mais tu as deux
sortes de façon d'écouter quelqu'un qui
te parle en fait ou tu écoutes quelqu'un
qui te parle en lisant et généralement
ton taux de ton attention c'est quoi 40
secondes ou tu as quelqu'un qui te parle
et en fait si je te parle tu vas avoir
une attention qui est plus importante
c'est pas moi qui vais t'apprendre ça
enfin si tu le sais ça de bien mieux que
moi et donc le fait d'être dans
l'interaction il parle avec les gens
d'ailleurs je réponds pas la même
manière à des journalistes
il y a des Français et parfois tu as des
émissions tu as les deux et mon équipe
me dit mais tu étais très bon avec les
Français tu étais pas terrible avec les
journalistes
réflexif avec les journalistes contrôle
on va faire attention à tous les mots et
puis ils ont beau les gens ils sont
encore là mais je parle à un français
tout d'un coup et parler spontanément et
donc c'est tu peux pas être dans le
contrôle tout le temps puis c'est pas
c'est pas intéressant j'ai pas envie de
donner à voir un personnage que je suis
pas non plus donc il faut essayer de
s'adapter puis après il y a des moments
où tu es crevés ou c'est plus dur de
faire un truc dynamique interactif puis
des moments où tu es très en forme très
hop où là tu es plus enjoué peut-être
des moments où tu es un peu déprimé donc
il est bas de la politique comme de
n'importe quel travail de ce point de
vue là bien sûr dans lequel tu es dans
lequel tu es plongé parfois donc il faut
il faut de la maîtrise sur le fond il
faut essayer d'être toujours
intelligible sur la forme et puis mon
équipe elle est là pour m'éviter aussi
de déborder par exemple si Ségolène
Tesla je pense qu'elle aurait coupé les
caméras et les micros depuis un certain
temps en disant on va arrêter parce que
là ça va être ça sera pas bon du tout
pour l'imaginer ministre tu vois on a
bien fait de pas l'inviter
mais les attaques que tu as pu recevoir
des parties opposants ou des membres de
ton propre parti en réalité je me suis
toujours dit mais de toute manière c'est
apolitique la santé publique il n'y a
pas de
droite de gauche de ce que tu veux
là-dessus rapport de tonnements comme on
dit c'est quand tu vois je crois que
c'est un sénateur que je vois dans les
couloirs du Sénat qui me dit bon
monsieur le ministre n'est pas les mêmes
camps mais vous faites un boulot
formidable ça va pas être facile on
aurait pas être à votre place on ferait
pareil que vous
merci ça me touche
merci et bon je vais vous poser une
question tout à l'heure je vous square
un peu mais bon vous prenez pas mal et
puis pas de problème mais je rentre dans
les disciples je m'assois la parole
monsieur le ministre comment
osez-vous avoir l'outrecuidance je vous
présenter devant nous avec le bilan qui
est le vôtre et bien je regarde
donc ça c'est ça c'est la galerie ça je
pense que ça plombe la politique donc ça
m'énerve pas moi contre moi voilà c'est
comme ça c'est couillon en fait ça sert
à rien c'est pas l'intérêt général si le
mec m'engueule en dehors et qui
m'engueulent dedans je respecte plus
voilà c'est anecdotique et alors les
collègues dans mon camp ils ont été
hyper hyper bien hyper bien franchement
c'est c'est senti porté soutenu c'était
pas facile pour eux parce que moi je
débarque et franchement ils ont été
géniaux après avec les oppositions des
fois j'ai pas réussi quoi je finis par
arriver à 23h dans l'hémicycle je crie
je hurle sur les députés si vous voulez
pas l'entendre sortez d'ici ce qui se
fait jamais on dit pas des députés de
sortir de l'hémicycle en fait ils sont
chez eux et moi je m'invite chez eux il
y avait un homme en surpoids âgé de 35
ans c'est ça la réalité mesdames et
messieurs les députés si vous voulez
elle est là la réalité de nos hôpitaux
elle est là la réalité nous invite donc
hôpitaux
[Applaudissements]
alors que nous soyons se battre pour
sauver des vies de cette manière-là ça
ne marche pas comme ça
il faut jamais faire ça ça s'appelle une
faute politique mais elle s'inscrit dans
un contexte où crevé 500 heures de débat
aux banques quand même sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire c'est un soir où je
sortais d'une d'un service de réa il y
avait des il y avait des jeunes qui
étaient en réa et on avait été marqué
avec Castex de voir c'est jeune là et
les députés de l'opposition viennent
nous battre sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire ils applaudissaient debout et
donc si tu veux j'arrive dans cette
émission et je me dis calme-toi
calme-toi calme-toi
et après je me dis merde donc ouais on
peut on peut craquer en fait des fois
est-ce que c'est grave c'est il vaut
mieux l'éviter c'est dramatique je crois
pas en tout cas suite à ce coup de
colère
je suis allé dans les hôpitaux les gens
les soignants me disaient plutôt merci
parce que nous on les avait comme ça
voilà ou alors ils avaient tous peur que
tu vois et si vous n'êtes pas contents
il y a une fonction il y a une pression
qui a jamais été connue en tout cas de
mémoire d'homme sur ce problème de santé
ou derrière tout ça il y a un homme en
fait qui peut aussi
[Musique]
parlons de l'enfance
sans transition perquisition octobre
2020 au moment de la deuxième vague
alors j'ai j'ai les mecs viennent chez
toi faire une perquisition tous les
casse-têtes
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ça je ne sais
pas attends il paraît qu'il y a une
preuve à l'intérieur les gars il faut
qu'on ouvre le casse-tête pourquoi elle
a été lancée qu'est-ce qui cherchait
potentiellement qui a lancé ça bah
pourquoi d'abord on a une justice qui
fonctionne je respecte ça mais aucun
problème avec ça il y a un juste en tout
cas c'est que tu te retrouves
potentiellement
devant un tribunal comme si tu avais
intentionn mal agit alors que quand tu
es à fond dans ce que tu fais tu n'as
pas l'impression tu as même les
certitudes de te pas agir avec une
mauvaise intention et puis l'origine des
plaintes c'est quand même des mecs pour
certains d'entre eux qui sont bien
connus aujourd'hui qui à la base
emporter plein de comptes moi parce que
j'en sais pas assez et qui après on
portait plein de copains parce que j'en
faisais trop donc si tu vois c'est juste
des mecs qui portent pleines il y en a
eu beaucoup très peu ont été retenus
j'attends d'être convoqué par la justice
et je m'expliquerai et voilà j'espère
que ça se passera bien on verra mais en
fait ce qui se passe et voilà une
accumulation de plein de certaines sont
retenus et du coup après la justice fait
son travail donc ça déclenché une
perquisition ça c'est le c'est un c'est
un moment de surprise
c'est 6h du matin j'étais couché à 2h30
et j'ouvre la porte et une perquisition
c'est quand on se met sur le côté et
c'est plus chez toi le temps que ces
personnes je crois 18 personnes avec des
brassards des talkie-walkie très
respectueux enfin qui rentre chez toi
dans le salon est pas très grand donc
c'est un peu la marge de l'empereur tu
sais le film de Luc Jacquet avec le
passage de la tour tout le monde en
costume dans le salon debout comme ça et
en fait il faut il faut tout alors
est-ce comment te dire dans ce genre de
moment je j'ai l'impression de faire un
pas de côté avec moi-même c'est à dire
que il y a le côté que je donne à voir
qui en l'occurrence est le mec sympa et
que j'aurais fait des cafés évidemment
j'ai coopérer dans mon téléphone machin
etc j'ai fait des blagues j'ai pas envie
de blaguer de regarder pas sur lui j'ai
planqué 40 millions de masques mais et
puis il y a le côté
perso où là je me dis réflexe de survie
pour plus tard je range ça dans un
tiroir en fait et je le ressortirai
quand j'aurai le temps et donc j'ai pas
subi la perquisition je l'ai vécu je
sais pas si tu vois la différence
ce qui fait que et puis j'ai voulu avoir
une forme de contrôle parce que si tu
perds par définition de contrôle et donc
j'aurais dit à 9h du matin j'ai un
rendez-vous à 9h du matin je serai en
rendez-vous mardi si on a terminé à 9h
du matin j'ai un rendez-vous donc ça a
pas durer très longtemps chez moi ça a
été plus long chez d'autres mais par
contre ouais c'est bizarre quoi après
mon ordinateur ouvrez votre navigateur
Internet tac tu cliques merci hop alors
et les mecs ils sont sur ton historique
internet en train de scroller et donc il
y a mais quelqu'un dans l'intimité c'est
très étrange tu vois le mec très sympa
il veut partager un moment avec moi donc
vous regardez engrenage vous êtes à la
saison 1
j'ai pas envie d'avoir cette discussion
j'ai pas envie du tout c'est plus facile
pour que ça se passe bien même pour soi
dans sa réception de surfer sur cette
vague là plutôt que de la refuser quoi
et puis la fierté j'ai ma fierté j'ai 18
personnes dans mon salon en train de
regarder dans les dans les piles de
vêtements si je cache des trucs donc je
vais avoir une sorte de contrôle bien
sûr après ils ont continué toute la
journée dans le dans les bureaux du
ministère ils ont voulu mettre sous
scellé la salle de la salle de contrôle
de gestion de crise sanitaire là
j'aurais dit en fait non parce que c'est
pas possible donc on a perdu une journée
de boulot c'est ça qui m'a qui m'a fait
un peu enragé et en fait le soir je suis
à Marseille parce que je fais une
émission de télé et c'est quand je
rentre au ministère que je vois en fait
que mon équipe est marqué mais en fait
tu vois des secrétaires qui comprennent
pas et des secrétaires qui sont en
larmes et là je me rends compte qu'en
fait
euh ce que moi j'ai classé comme étant
une expérience de vie à relire ça a été
pris avec violence par les autres avec
un sentiment d'injustice et donc j'ai
leur expliquer c'est normal que la
justice fasse ça ça veut pas dire qu'on
a quoi que ce soit se reprocher ça veut
dire qu'ils sont obligés de regarder
dans le détail s'il y a des choses qui
peuvent nous être reprochés et il faut
accepter ça et on continue de travailler
et on remonte en scène et on est remonté
en salle donc ta vie te dis pas
forcément qu'un jour tu seras amené à
prononcer la phrase je veux parler à mon
avocat
c'est voilà je veux mon avocat c'est
très bizarre en fait tu as l'impression
que tu vis une vie qui n'est pas la
tienne il y a eu la deuxième vague tu as
tu apprends que l'Assemblée nationale à
voter pour l'arrêt de l'état d'urgence
au 15 décembre c'est quoi ta réaction à
ce moment-là ma question c'est est-ce
que naïvement vous êtes dit tu perds
tout le monde va nous suivre et va nous
aider un certain temps parce qu'on
dépose un peu les armes est-ce qu'il y a
eu cette idée là ça a été une réalité en
mars 2020 premier confinement unité
nationale j'ai trouvé ça super agréable
et à la hauteur et après c'est plus
compliqué on est déplacements dans les
villes où je vais annoncer chez le
porteur de mauvaises nouvelles que
généralement quand j'allais dans une
ville c'est que tu es que le covid
repartait et donc il avait falloir
fermer les trucs et des élus avec
lesquels ça a été impeccable et qui sont
pas de mon bord je cite Martine Aubry
par exemple que je connaissais pas avant
tout était
mort bien des villes où c'était
l'horreur en tout cas plus compliquée et
avec une partie des élus pas tous mais
une partie des élus de Marseille ça a
été je débarque dans la ville je suis
dans le cortège avec le préfet les gens
savent que j'arrive dans la ville et les
courses ils courses la voiture en
insultant parce que en fait je viens
leur dire qu'on va fermer les bars et
les réseaux parce que c'est en train de
flamber dans la ville et une
incompréhension et sans doute des
maladresses aussi de notre côté et donc
c'est c'est ce récit très humain aussi
de des rapports qu'on peut entretenir
avec des élus et un élu peut faire
complètement basculer une logique de
crise sanitaire et là où les élus ont
été complètement je pense au maire de
Dunkerque qui abandonné a dit dans le
carnaval de Dunkerque on arrête
effectivement le ministre a raison il
faut qu'on se protège
ça se passe bien la décision est
acceptée dans les endroits où tu as des
élus qui ont dit mais c'est pas ce que
vous nous en voulez vous faites
n'importe quoi en fait la vision de la
population elle était quasi impossible
et en fait tu vois juste l'impact que ça
sur les gens donc c'est le moment tu en
rage un peu ouais quand on est
vexination arrive on a un gros retard
sur les autres pays comme l'Allemagne si
je dis pas de bêtises et au final on les
dépasse et ça ça m'intéresse de savoir
comment on est passé du pays qui vaccine
le moins vite à celui qui vaccine le
plus grand nombre jardin la française et
peur de manquer on a pensé notre
vaccination avec des règles de
priorisation les personnes âgées les
EHPAD etc les plus fragiles et donc on
voulait être sûr d'avoir vacciné toutes
les personnes fragiles avant de
commencer à vacciner les autres et sauf
que les personnes fragiles dans les
EHPAD ça prend du temps parce qu'il y a
une histoire de consentement parce qu'il
fallait organiser les transports les
trucs logistiques et compagnies alors
que les Allemands ils ont ouvert des
centres ils ont dit bah allez on y va on
vaccinent et donc le début était cata
c'est même enfin moi j'étais piteux
honteux de voir que on avait vacciné
Mauricette et que les Allemands étaient
à 18000 et puis à 60 000
[Musique]
je vois le discours de l'intervention du
président de la République le 31 au soir
qui parle des lenteurs injustifiés moi
en fait je vais pas faire la fête ce
soir je vais me remettre à travailler
je meurs
c'était l'enfer mais en même temps je
savais qu'on aurait trop tard et en même
temps je savais qu'il fallait pas qu'on
est du retard donc j'en doute la totale
responsabilité de ce démarrage parce que
c'est moi qui qui était pilotait tout ça
j'essaie de l'expliquer mais de fait
aujourd'hui on comprend mieux qu'à
l'époque mais à l'époque c'était ouais
très très très très très très compliqué
je crois que tu as le soir de Noël c'est
le 24 décembre je le retrouve à appeler
un responsable d'un centre logistique
dans la région lyonnaise parce qu'il
stocke des super congélateurs avec des
vaccins dedans et moi j'appelle ministre
j'appelle monsieur en lisant écoutez la
livraison des vaccins à Bordeaux c'est
pas faite par la route on avait du
retard sur le super congélateur on l'a
maintenant est-ce que vous avez le moyen
de faire décoller demain un avion un
petit avion suffisamment stable parce
que les brins d'arrêt de messager ils
sont fra
réfrigérer pour m'emmener des vaccins à
Bordeaux ce serait sympa qui dit vous
êtes qui Olivier
bonjour
c'est vraiment le 24 décembre genre il
va être l'heure du dîner quoi
qu'est-ce que vous me voulez puis quand
il a compris que j'étais en ligne
pourquoi vous faites ça je dis mais
parce que là on s'y met tous en fait et
donc il fallait qu'on accélère dans cet
état dingue c'était dingue le monsieur
l'a fait d'ailleurs merci c'est vrai il
t'a cru quoi au bout d'un moment tu es
obligé d'appeler en visio ça m'arrive
des fois que les gens raccroche c'est
quand il y a 2 ans je vais vous donner
au Téléthon bonjour je donne au Téléthon
votre nom de famille verront votre
prénom Olivier allez au revoir monsieur
attention c'est peut-être justement
parce qu'ils t'ont cru qu'ils ont
accroché
c'est un moment donné c'est plus le
virus qui a été possible pris pour cible
justement c'était le vaccin ton regard
sur les sur les Antibes où ton regard
sur l'argument que du coup le vaccin
n'évitait pas d'avoir le virus quand
comment comment tu as pu jongler avec ça
en fait donc les gens qui voulaient pas
du vaccin alors il y a ceux qui disaient
que c'était un complot que nous même on
sait pas vacciné et que c'est les labos
qui nous payaient etc
je mets ça de côté toute petite forge de
la population perdue pour la cause en
tout cas dans la période il y a une
partie de la population qui disait mais
votre vaccin vous me dit qu'il est
efficace mais regardez il n'empêche pas
de tomber malade ouais et l'empêche pas
enfin il réduit le risque de tomber
malade sans doute et si vous êtes
vacciné vous avez moins de risques de
mourir si vous attrapez la maladie et on
vous répondez oui mais ça empêche pas
tous oui mais encore une fois le vaccin
il vous empêche de mourir il réduit les
risques de mourir et les réduit
fortement et donc il va protéger les
gens très fragiles mais pour que ça
fonctionne il faut qu'on soit tous
protégé parce que si on est tous
protégés collectivement mine de rien
même si l'impact sur la circulation du
virus il est pas 100% ça va réduire le
risque qu'on se transmette le virus dans
la population et donc d'aller contaminer
des personnes fragiles et notamment il y
a des gens qui malgré le fait qu'ils
soient vacciné parce qu'ils sont les
mieux déprimés et autres en fait ils ne
sont pas protégés et ces gens là on en a
dans les hôpitaux beaucoup et il meurent
et donc collectivement on doit faire ce
geste qu'on y croit ou non de se
protéger pour protéger les autres c'est
pas simple
c'est très simple et donc tu peux
rentrer dans des débats sans fin où les
gens te disent mais ça il y a du coup
pas trop d'énergie à prendre avec les
anti vaccins à ce moment-là et juste
continuer à donner les bons arguments ça
a été ça je voulais passer surtout
l'énergie pour pour faire en sorte que
les gens éloignés de système de soins
parce que c'est eux qu'on voyait
beaucoup dans les hôpitaux dans les
quartiers populaires les gens pauvres
qui par définition enfin ont plus de
risques d'avoir des comorbidités
c'est-à-dire des maladies cardiaques ont
pulmonaires et c'est eux que je voyais
dans les hôpitaux non vaccinés donc et
ils étaient pas vaccinés ils étaient pas
non vaccinés parce qu'ils étaient
antilax mais parce qu'ils étaient loin
du système de soins donc il a fallu
qu'on fasse du aller vers on développe
des bus qui aille au pied des tours
d'immeubles qu'on va accéder dans les
centres commerciaux qu'on allait faire
du porte-à-porte les gens pour leur dire
s'il vous plaît protégez-vous parce que
c'est ces vilains qu'on voulait aussi
sauver quand toi tu découvres que tu es
positif au covid
j'ai plein de questions guiliane mais
est-ce que tu hésites aller annoncer
publiquement est-ce que quand on est le
ministre de la Santé et qu'on a une
fièvre de 40 degrés on prend quand même
le temps de se soigner ou est-ce qu'on
peut pas se le permettre c'est ce qu'on
doit être fonctionnel quand j'ai le test
je suis malade à un moment donné fier je
suis jamais malade et la fièvre pas bien
je teste négatif négatif négatif puis un
jour positif
en fait je suis symptomatique depuis 4
ou 5 jours il doit rester 2 ou 3 jours
en fait et après et donc je me dis en
fait ça va être le weekend je peux
m'isoler chez moi mais soigner et
pendant une fraction de seconde je me
dis est-ce que je communique et puis
j'appelle mon équipe évidemment allez on
appelle machin et après je télétravail
je fais une conférence visioconférence
avec Jean-Michel Blanquer et les et le
monde enseignant qui va durer genre 3
heures et où j'ai 42 fièvre je suis
derrière mon écran et je dois intervenir
et je suis vraiment pas bien sûr après
ça ça
j'ai bossé j'étais travailler depuis
chez moi et tout et j'en rageais d'être
tombé malade après mais comme tous les
mecs je suis malade donc je vais mourir
donc
et médecin c'est une double raison de
mourir dès que tu es malade
mais est-ce que tu as des regrets en
tant qu'homme sur sur ce qui s'est passé
est-ce que si on te donnait une baguette
magique tu pourrais changer ça alors tu
pourrais changer ça sans la connaissance
actuelle c'est à dire juste à posteriori
des choses que tu as fait ou dites c'est
dur du coup ta question parce que avec
en prenant en compte ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui forcément sinon ce serait ce
serait ce serait ridicule de dire
l'inverse il y a jamais eu de décision
contrainte peut-être que pour revenir
sur out j'aurais dû
fermer le banc tout de suite avec
peut-être une fermeté mais je suis pas
sûr que l'effet aurait été positif ça
peut être catalyseur aussi voilà en fait
c'était ça la difficulté mais je rêvais
de dire aux gens en fait c'est n'importe
quoi et ma conviction c'est que ça ne
peut pas être autre chose que n'importe
quoi parce que c'est pas démontré mais
il y avait cette petite part qui disait
tant qu'on a pas démontré l'inverse
c'est compliqué c'est la dernière
question est-ce que tu es soulagé tu
peux être ministre de la Santé au final
je si c'était à refaire et si on me
rappelait pendant que je suis en train
de pique-niquer avec mes enfants sur ce
chaîne magnifique à côté de Grenoble
pour me proposer de prendre le job je je
suis honoré la confiance qui m'a été
faite conscient que tout n'a pas été
parfait loin sans faut persuadé d'avoir
donné vraiment le maximum c'est la
première fois depuis mes 18 ans que je
m'occupe plus de santé d'une manière ou
d'une autre donc c'est assez bizarre
après il faut qu'on apprenne de tout ça
il faut qu'on emmène il faut qu'on sache
faire s'il y a une crise sanitaire ou
autre qui survient à nouveau qu'on garde
les compétences acquises et puis il faut
qu'on pense nos plaies il faut qu'à un
moment donné on puisse
avoir ce temps de recueillement
collectif ce temps pour cicatriser il
faut qu'on honore la mémoire de des gens
qui sont morts du covid ou des gens qui
ont eu peur ou des gens qui ont perdu
des proches je pense que c'est
fondamental on en est pas là parce qu'on
en est pas sorti et que on n'est jamais
fabriqué à nouveau variant mais enfin le
temps qui s'écoule nous montre que le
risque qu'on revive le passé s'éloigne
ça veut pas dire que c'est fini c'est
pas si on est à la l'épilogue d'un
mauvais roman ou à la page 12 un livre
d'anticipation
je pense qu'on est à l'épilogue qu'on
s'en rapproche mais on n'a pas la
certitude le confinement c'était pas une
période simple pour personne c'est
incroyable qu'Olivier vérançovni à cette
interview n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
pour voir le prochain à très bientôt
Ciao